more than 3500 people have been stuck
aboard a Grand Princess cruise ship off
the coast of California for days now you
probably heard about this and they're
stranded there due to the spread of the
corona virus 21 passengers aboard the
ship have tested positive for the virus
now this has been an ordeal for
everybody on board but no one has
suffered more than the stand-up comic
who was booked to entertain on the
cruise ship guys name is Lenny Dugan and
he was supposed to do only three
half-hour shows over four days but
because of the quarantine he's currently
on his 57th straight hour of stand-up
comedy we are the only show to have
footage of his Marathon comedy set take
a look anyone anyone playing
shuffleboard or as I call it checkers
with rakes what's the deal with that I
mean it's like I want to play a game and
I want to do yard work wrapping it up no
I like that the bartender's seem to have
a sense of humor about it has anyone
tried their quarantine ease
I like that here's my impression of Al
Pacino learning where the coronavirus is
from whoo ha whoo ha it's kind of like
when he used to do hoo-hah kind of scent
of a woman era anyway God where where is
the Somali pirate when you need one you
know so let me get this straight this
virus is young and Asian why isn't Woody
Allen dating it too soon ye you want me
to bring the ventriloquist back no no
that's what mercurial